بين spacex tesla وشركة Solarcity الثالثة التابعة لشركة
Solarcity ،
فأنا جميعًا على
اطلاع دائم على موقع cnn.com ، وهو يوم ضخم لإعلان شركة tesla ،
لماذا الآن
حسنًا وعدد من الأسباب آه نحن في
الواقع لسنا بحاجة
إلى عائدات الاكتتاب من أجل  يعتقد
الكثير من الناس
أننا نفعل ذلك ، ولكن هذا هو الحال في الواقع
مع قرض voe
وباستثمار موجود مسبقًا ،
هذا هو النموذج بالطريقة التي يتم طرحها
في عام 2012.
كان ipo في
الواقع هو جمع الأموال من أجل
التطوير المتوازي لبعض
الاختلافات الإضافية على منصة النموذج
أه لمنحنا القليل من
الحماية الإضافية في حالة أن النموذج يستغرق وقتًا
أطول من المتوقع
وأيضًا لتوفير بعض أه
كمية صغيرة من السيولة لـ  أنا
والآخرون أه
في ذلك الموجود في الملكية الفكرية ، فأنا أبيع
خمسة في المائة فقط من ممتلكاتي ولا
أميل إلى القول أكثر من ذلك لأكون
واضحًا وهذا جزء من جزء من اتفاقية الظبية
التي يجب عليك التمسك بها
65 في المئة مشترك
نعم صحيح بالنسبة لمقتنياتي ،
فلنتحدث عن الطراز ،
هذا هو أنه سيكلف حوالي
نصف ما تكلفه سيارة رودستر حوالي
خمسين ألف
دولار ، والهدف هو أن يكون هذا الطرح في عام
2012. لكنك قلته للتو
في حال تطلب الأمر  أطول من المتوقع
، هذا جدول زمني صارم حقًا ،
أعني هل تعتقد حقًا
أنه يمكنك إخراجها وتشغيل
20000 منها
بحلول عام 2012 لأن الأمل جيد يجب أن
أكون واضحًا
لأن أولئك الذين يستثمرون في ipr
يدركون ذلك لأننا  لقد مررنا
بالطريق بأكمله ، أظهر أن كل أولئك الذين رأوا
الطريق الصافي كان يجب أن يروا
أننا نعتزم بدء الإنتاج في
منتصف عام 2012 ، يستغرق الأمر دائمًا بعض
الوقت لتجهيز خط الإنتاج ،
لذلك نتوقع أن يكون في 20  معدل تشغيل 000 وحدة في
السنة أه بحلول أوائل عام 2013 ، لذا
سيكون عام 2013 هو العام الأول الذي سنقوم فيه بعمل
20000 وحدة
كما تعتقد أن تسلا
ستبدو في غضون خمس سنوات ، لقد تغيرت هذه الشركة
كثيرًا في السنوات القليلة
الماضية
بشكل جيد.  أعرف الثاني ما آمل  نحن
نقوم خلال خمس سنوات بصنع سياراتنا
في السوق الشامل
ومن ثم كان هذا هو الهدف حقًا
منذ البداية ، وكان
حلمي في تسلا هو صنع
سيارات كهربائية في السوق الشامل
، وهذا ما تعلمون أننا على
وشك القيام به  للقيام بالخطوة ، لقد قمنا بالخطوة الأولى
من ذلك
مع سيارة رودستر التي تعرف أن
الحجم المرتفع للسعر المنخفض الآن نحن ننتقل
إلى
الحجم المتوسط للسعر المتوسط ومن ثم نأمل في غضون خ
س سنوات ربما ست سنوات نحن أيضًا
إنتاج السيارة الكهربائية في السوق الشامل
وهذا هو الحلم النهائي
بالنسبة لي بالنسبة لشركة تسلا التي تبحث في تسلا ،
فهذه شركة ناشئة مثل العديد من
الشركات الناشئة التي تخسر فيها أموالًا ، وقد
خسرت الشركة حوالي 260 مليون دولار منذ
إنشائها ،
فأنت تريد  الجمهور للاستثمار في تسلا ،
ما الذي يمكنك قوله لطمأنة المستثمرين
الذين قد يكون لديهم أسئلة حول
الربحية المحتملة هنا
جيدًا ، نعم ، غالبًا ما نتلقى هذا السؤال
، الشيء المهم الذي يجب أخذه في
الاعتبار هو أنه إذا كانت تسلا فقط
قررنا فقط أن نكون
شركة سيارات رياضية ونبيع قطارات الطاقة
لشركات أخرى مثل الموت
لدايملر لتويوتا ، سنكون مربحين
وهذا اعتبار مهم ،
لكننا نختار عدم القيام بذلك ،
فنحن نختار بدلاً من ذلك إعادة استثمار تلك
الأرباح وجمع الأموال الإضافية
لزيادة حجم الإنتاج
وإنتاج النماذج التي
تزيد حجم الإنتاج بمقدار 30 ضعفًا ، وربما
يزيد حجم الإنتاج بمقدار 40 مرة
عن سيارتنا الرياضية ، ومن المستحيل فقط
إذا كنت تمر بهذا
النوع من
النمو لتظل مربحة  ككل